il n'y avait que sept personnes
aujourd'hui présente devant le tribunal
correctionnel à paris sept hommes
originaires principalement de province
la présidente a commencé par montrer des
images de graffitis mise sur les piliers
de l'arc de triomphe ce jour là c'était
le 1er décembre 2018 la journée la plus
violente du mouvement des gilet jaune
lors de l'acte iii
il y avait eu d'importantes dégradations
à l'arc de triomphe pour un million
d'euros en tout une véritable
profanation
pour l'avocat d'une association aux
parties civiles de défense du patrimoine
je vous propose de l'écouter a lyon
c'est évidemment un monument d'abord
patrimoniale historique s'est également
amusé a été saccagé mais c'est un lieu
de mémoire national d'unité nationale
gérée à traverser tous les régimes
initié par napoléon j'irai sauvé par la
restauration est réutilisé par la
république puisque le soldat inconnu
on sait tous de 1920 repose dans cette
cette enceinte qui est-il qui est un
lieu sacré patriotique tous les français
se retrouvent présent aussi à ce procès
pour apporter leur soutien aux prévenus
des militants d gilet jaune pour la
plupart je vous propose d'écouter faouzi
lellouche militants gilet jaune que j'ai
pu interviewer au début de ce procès
c'est facile de mettre ça sur le dos de
la profanation parce qu'à un moment
donné faut vous dire aussi que il y
avait un mutisme et un dénigrement
complet du gouvernement et donc on peut
pas pousser les gens à bout
et puis après c'est s'étonner que les
gens ne sont pas contents
donc c'est vrai qu'on était on était
énormément de monde ce jour-là comme on
était dans les débuts dans dans les
premiers actes mais faut voir aussi
qu'on nous a amenés là moi je me
souviens on a voulu se présenter sur les
champs-elysées c'était un peu compliqué
d'y rentrer fallait présenter ses
papiers
et puis comme un seul homme on a conduit
tout le monde vers l'arc de triomphe et
on nous a enfermés là bas dans une nasse
géante
il nous a fallu presque moi il m'a fallu
trois heures pour en sortir et je peux
vous dire sur les sous le coude et des
ailes bd des gaz lacrymogènes et voilà
donc ça aurait pu être n'importe qui
donc un moment donné faut pas s'étonner
qu'il ya des dommages collatéraux 400
personnes avaient été arrêtées ce
jour-là mais la justice avait eu du mal
à définir des responsabilités ferme sur
des actes de dégradations majeures
sept autres personnes vont être jugées
pour de simples intrusion dans
l'allemand devant des tribunaux de
police quoi qu'il en soit ici le
résultat de ce procès il est attendu
vendredi